that was awful
well oh my god i have mouse lips kinky
seven
twice i mean he must think i'm trolling
him
the moment people ask me about my mice
i've i've now slipped the bong cloud
twice twice not even once
[Music]
oh yeah buckle in ladies and gentlemen
buckley no music
we are focusing oh my god and i already
know oh my god
oh my god that's so funny do you see how
my mouse looks guys i i played um
it's hilarious i i played oh god
what is he doing though jesus
oh my god we are playing
we are both playing a horrible game
right now
ah oh my god that was horrific
how did i thank you a beastie for the
bits
that was awful well
oh my god i have mouse lips kinky seven
twice i mean he must think i'm trolling
him
the moment people ask me about my mice
i've i've now slipped the bong cloud
twice twice not even once
okay but i've actually and i've gotten
great positions both times
and i've lost them both it seems now
sorry brandon i didn't mean to chicken
out on you it's just that
it's so rare for me to get a chance to
play eric
he's obviously not going to make it this
time
what am i doing jesus
it's horrible
come on daniel make moves jesus what is
wrong with me
all right
spending a little bit longer in the
opening
eric this is very dangerous in the open
air this does not look good
all right so this is over over 1k
playing 32nd with eric welcome everybody
hope all i hope you guys are all
doing well
something is a bit wrong with the way
with my mouse i don't know what it is
just not quite crisp in my motions take
it
thank you proper again and okay proper
thank you
obviously he's not going to make it i'm
getting just lucky with the clock
again all right
i just think we have a lot of viewers i
don't i'm not always unjustly some
people are watching because they enjoy
maybe
but thank you man with the raid 21 thank
you welcome
no problem man i appreciate it you're
very sweet
any min raid is a good ride
jam jam five more to the comunidad
thank you john i really appreciate it
the man
oh my god he knew i would do that are
you freaking no this time
that was actually oh i'm getting crushed
here if i win this
guys please ah okay he's not taking any
of the pieces i am offering him
only the pawns but he's playing really
well
i'm trying my best here guys trying my
best
ah get out make a mate threat
okay uh check
unbelievable i'm gonna win it
unbelievable
yeah yeah yeah
eric is going after me in the openings
jesus
it's also much faster than the openings
it's getting warmed up jim jim again
with 500 bits thank you
just gonna go g4 he's actually playing a
positional masterpiece right now
as he often does in 30-second chess
rookie for you
unbelievable unbelievable
okay i'm actually disbelief that the
amount of luck that i am benefiting from
in every game
that being said don't mess with
don't mess with me when i'm warmed up
and i have some coffee in my system
alright 33.
i think i've learned from brandon to
predict moves and it was bad
he's gonna avoid adoption eric does not
like getting it up let me tell you
he is good at awaiting it
or not
there we go not that anybody cares
leading the charge here let's get some
energy in the house boys
borrowing some transparent criminology
draw
man one thing that's that's not going
well for me is the openings
eric is just he's going out of the gate
oh god he's just
crushing me out of these openings
oh my god what is he doing holy smokes
what is this
am i losing though i might be i have to
draw
ah [ __ ] it
unbelievable holy smokes
no i dropped a piece this is over
unless he gets tilted and drops this
game which is not possible
and if he pre-moves like this i'm going
to stalemate him
i will find a way be careful eric up
against the stalemate mister
oh that was close if he would have
promoted there that was a stalemate
okay i need to play faster and better in
the opening
more pre-moves less bs
let's give him a taste of his own
medicine
and he's just too fast yeah this is over
i had made in one
i mated him
since you get on this stream
that was the most unexpected thing ever
and now eric is mad though and he's
playing incredibly well
move daniel jesus make a goddamn move
it's horrible
yeah i got to get him on the premiums
he's pre-moving a lot
he's not doing it very accurately
he wants to check with me let him do
that
okay so i can stay here go here
what's wrong with my freaking settings
i'm just not
i'm trying to play like jeffrey against
carl
oh his rook is trapped
[Applause]
holy smokes another installment from jim
jim thank you
appreciate it jim
no but he he's trapped this this i did
see
and boom goes the dynamite
unbelievable i want d5 okay not over yet
let's get all the pieces in he's tilted
he will blender
i've got to use my chins
keep pieces on the board
you
yeah that was close
20 games in good score
tilted is a poker thing that has been
reapportioned to chess
but people employ it way too liberally
and trust people just
call everything tilted even when someone
is playing really well like eric is
right now
he's crushing me completely
i gotta get a passer this one pass pawn
could decide the game
if i push it correctly well i'm not
i just gotta get lucky with the pre-move
basically
basically all i can do
yeah he's crushing me every game
you
this one i gotta win
oh my god any draws you found a drone
freaking rascal
completely winning end game jesus
there's a piece
at this
this is over i think
because of this and this and this
and this okay great good
the brake is tight he's playing well
but tilting somewhat
if he takes out a fork
i need to get out of there asap
oh my god he's got made holy smokes he's
gonna make me isn't he
get out
oh god oh god guys please pray with me
okay we're good
okay great welcome everybody to a
bullet match with eric hansen hobalas
hope all are well
and enjoying the match oh my god i could
have taken that how could i have known
he does
that how could i know that he does
something like this yeah
i want to thank everybody who decided to
support
all appreciated very much it all helps
me keep going i appreciate it thank you
everybody for watching
and for the incredible community and
proper as i speak
gifting the bits carrying that train
appreciate a proffer
i don't like what i just did there
in fact what i just did there was
criminally bad
i will try to remedy the situation
you've mouse slipped like five times
then
all right grant not satisfied by the
match jesus
well music is tough when i'm actually
trying to focus and beat somebody
but i'll play some music
and then i'm gonna keep i'm gonna play a
song called let's kill grant
charlotte
charlotte chess center that's not saying
anything that must mean i'm playing well
you
you
all right
be soothed by the sound of the moves
the hills are alive the sound of music
okay i'm gonna do
now i got connected passers now let's
try to actually play a good end game
which i already i have already failed to
do
but this is over
the knight is trapped yes it is we don't
even need to take back
yep
get out of here scooter thank you so
much for the support and the sub
appreciate it very much thank you
same
one piece
tonight trapped
all right
trying to get the queen side pressured
positional sack followed by bishop a6
okay that is a really annoying nasty
little move i have this
[Music]
goodbye
i need to remedy this by getting the
knight here
take this guy okay at least i i'm not
gonna get checkmated that quickly here
all right let's get him
that was a mouse slip another one
oh my god you little rascal eric he was
waiting and
waiting in store for that
so i gotta surprise my own for him
all right
yeah this is a bad engine
sometimes he just plays a really really
nice game
very difficult to survive in such a
situation
wow that was ridiculous
i'll need to do the same here play a
nice game to just
cannot let him win two in a row it's
okay to lose one it's not okay to lose
two
that's that's going to be the key to
stopping eric from
getting back into the match
you
okay
i got a reasonable position here
the oh it's interesting because the
openings he's still very quick
oh yeah okay that's fine that's fine
now i'll need to play a textbook end
game with no time on the clock
i'm already not doing good job of
oh god what am i doing oh my god this is
horrible
what am i freaking doing jesus
okay that was bad
maybe 50 games that's enough
what is this that oh oh he took a piece
there oh my god
i thought that was a blunder i was like
what
another chance at a textbook end game
this time i'm intent doing a superior
job
still too slow hope you guys are
enjoying the match
i know 30 seconds is not everyone's cup
of tea but it's been a while since i
played eric
man i need to i need to prevent it from
doing this he's done this this whole a3
business
way too many times shame you know pull
me one stream on me etc
he's fooled me too many times it's shame
on me basically
i need to try to preserve this last
remaining pawn
and i'm going to win
well
wow i just want it back that's kind of
fun
whoa let's go my main
air cup that's what we're talking about
some serious energy here thank you
i should have gone d5 and i knew exactly
what to do
if i win this i have a good feeling
about this actually i have a very good
feeling about this
for some reason or not b4 is a really
nice move by eric
very nice play by eric here
basically throughout the entire match
she's not playing as he usually does
i've just been getting very lucky
as i usually do i told you guys i had a
good feeling about this
thank you so much
he did the same thing there okay i need
to trade and i'll need to win this
damn how do you know that how did he
know not to pre-move
again the key is going to be not to lose
two in a row i mean
i will if i lose one fine
not good but fine i lose two very bad
all right
it's all good air cuff it's a team
effort
it's a team effort the energy is a team
effort
i'm gonna crush her
this is a this is a rough stretch right
now
this is a rough stretch
whoa gem jam
thank you
this is where i need to stuff it up
and squash the soaps of a comeback
it's being annoying
takes ah
oh my god he how did he do that
still better
terrible game but i need to win a couple
here
how did he know
holy smokes we got nicholas theodoru
my voice is going jesus thank you
nicholas appreciate it
okay what do we do here
horrible starting to lose we're just
exchanging baskets here
which is not acceptable
he's picking it up
all right so
i maybe should be able to win
nope
alright now
time to actually oh my god knight
episode
well it's actually not the end of the
world
believe it or not but now he's got i've
got
555 pieces for
ah so goddamn tricky
there we go got him
all right big big win right there
trying to ride out the wave here
no it's not going to cut it
at all
unbelievably good
in one move
unbelievable how bad can you get
how bad can you get
lucky as hell it was just too fast